Deepwater Horizon was directed by Peter
Berg and stars Mark Wahlberg and is the
true story of the workers caught in the
horrible oil disaster that occurred on
Deepwater Horizon
that was so widely publicized as the
worst oil disaster in US history and
this is the story of the people who were
caught in the middle of this horrible
day the events leading up to this
disaster how it possibly could have been
prevented and how these people survived
as well as being a tribute to those who
did not survive now as I said this was
directed by Peter Berg this is not the
first true story that Peter Berg has
made with Mark Wahlberg the last one was
the lone survivor and in fact this isn't
going to be the last they also have a
movie called Patriots day coming out
that is also based on true events so
this is actually just moving number two
in their unofficial based on true events
trilogy and just so you guys know please
stay tuned to the end of this video
because I'm doing a special promotion
with Squarespace and all my viewers to
our web designers I'm excited to share
that promotion with you guys I've been a
fan of Peter Burke for quite some time I
really like the rundown I find that a
very underrated action film Battleship
let's just all agree that was a mistake
as soon as the disaster begins Deepwater
Horizon was a non-stop intense ride of
immaculate sound design technical
mastery it's very easy to watch a film
like this that is technically nonstop
action and just think that it's mindless
without ever actually realizing how much
work truly goes in to the technical
things on display in this film which are
to be lauded this is a very realistic
and gritty depiction of a terrible
disaster there's never a moment in this
movie where I went that's a Hollywood
moment that's one of those fake moments
that makes us feel like we're watching a
movie this film feels very realistic
aside from some up-close views of inside
the oil pipe where we see gear shifting
and stuff which even though shots were
very grainy and they felt almost like
one of those tube webcams had been stuck
down there it didn't feel like we were
watching a Michael Bay movie so to speak
it felt very in the moment and very real
time and that was captured extremely
well if I'm being totally honest it's
the same basic structure of lone
survivor we set up some
likeable people in the middle of a
terrible situation and once that
situation goes down and hits the
fan it's nonstop from there to the end
just like lone survivor but it works it
really works in this film and a lot of
that is due to a surprisingly effective
first act these characters that are set
up are actually very well drawn and
that's something that definitely
surprised me I expected this film to be
technically masterful in regards to all
of the stunt work and the explosions and
the acting I expected all of that to be
done very well what surprised me was how
much I actually cared about these people
because it takes that entire first act
to set up likeable workers that have a
very realistic rapport with one another
they tell each other jokes there's a
great scene where Mark Wahlberg reminded
me of me he takes a lot of pride in his
office being perfect and he asks someone
who's leaving his office you touch any
of my you touch any of my he's
like no man touching your stuff he goes
in his office and things are moved and
turned around and it reminded me of me
whenever a family member comes in here
and borrows one of my blu-rays and puts
them back crooked this is me oh my god
touch my you touch my touch my
people touching my just leave
my loans my I love that quirk
that was given to his character his OCD
habits with the things that he collected
or that he appreciated because him I I
can relate to that but his family life
with his young daughter who has a school
project and his wife Kate Hudson these
are all things that help us care more
about his character and in some movies
they just take the time to be like look
he has a family now care about him oh
maybe his wife is pregnant or something
care about him because of those things
they really do take the time to set up a
natural environment in which all of
these people exist and work and it feels
completely real and so when the really
bad stuff starts happening you really do
care for these characters and you want
them to get out of this situation Kurt
Russell is also really good in this
movie and there is a fantastic moment
between him and John Malkovich who I did
not know was in this movie who plays one
of the higher-ups at BP and this moment
occurs towards the halfway point of the
movie and
won't rent it for you but it gave me
goosebumps it was chilling it spoke
everything that needed to be said with
no one even speaking a word and that's
good direction and that's good acting
the film also explores briefly towards
the end our tendency to point blame and
start pointing fingers at people when we
don't really know all the facts and
that's something that I thought was
really profound to be included in this
film that some are just saying is an
action thriller but it really is a lot
more than that as for flaws I suppose
it's the same that I might have a lone
survivor it's sort of like you're just
in it and it's so intense and then when
it ends you're like oh man like I feel
like I never actually breathed or had a
moment to breathe but in a film like
this that works because no one in this
situation had a moment to breathe either
they were all just in it and it had to
happen right now and so you don't always
get these theatrical things that were so
used to getting to make us feel like
we're watching a film and I like that
about this film guys in the end
Deepwater Horizon was an extremely
intense movie that depicted events that
happened to people that maybe could have
been prevented
and it displayed them in a surprisingly
mature way and that's something that I
really enjoyed and I'm gonna give
deepwater horizon and a - if you are a
fan of lone survivor I think this movie
will probably be up your alley because
it's very similar it's just a different
subject with certain things changed
around but it's well done so like I said
guys I'm currently running a promotion
with Squarespace this is a very very
cool service that allows you to create
your own website in an extremely easy
way if you go to squarespace.com slash
Chris Stockman you can get 10% off your
first purchase and start your free trial
today now what they offer is this a free
custom domain Squarespace mix adding a
domain to your site simple if you sign
up for a year you'll receive a custom
domain for free for a year they have
beautiful templates you can design a
best-in-class
online store with squarespace's
award-winning templates Squarespace is
also trusted by hundreds of thousands of
savvy shop owners around the world
including all the tools you need to
track inventory process orders and send
custom emails and one intuitive
interface I started out in web design
when I was a teenager I made my own
website tried to do my
on movie reviews and that's actually
what got me started and eventually I
left over to YouTube so what I would
suggest to you guys is if you are into
web design check out squarespace.com
slash Chris Stockman use my last name
stuckman and get 10% off for a free
trial and you guys can start your own
website and see what you can do with it
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I greatly appreciate it check
out deepwater horizon I think it is
definitely worth your time it is a very
intense experience and look forward to
this weekend because I'm going to be
having some more new classic reviews for
you coming more in my ring series of
reviews more in my Harry Potter series
of reviews and maybe a secret series
starting very soon thank you so much
guys for watching and if you liked this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you